all right y'all we have reached the end
of the hour but I have one more
uplifting story to share this is what
I'm
liking if you can see it you can be it
that's the idea behind a line of female
firefighter dolls these are so cute they
were created by an actual firefighter
who says girls used to approach her
saying they didn't know women could
actually do this job it motivate I love
these dolls it motivated her to design
dolls like this that would Inspire girls
from an early age we have her on the
line right now watching on NBC Miami
everybody please say hello to Lieutenant
Tina gerer of the Miami dve County fire
rescue
hello hi tell I love these dolls Oh my
God my girl is g to love this have you
seen the impact that the dolls have made
yes I have um I designed them like you
said because I still have little girls
coming up to me saying are you really a
firefighter or I didn't know girls can
be firefighters so I thought how am I
going to get this out to little girls to
know that they can be fire firefighters
too yeah so that's why I designed the
doll and they've been going out to kids
and I've had a mom actually come up to
me and she said I have to tell you the
story about my daughter and I go okay
and she goes my daughter came up to me
and told me that she wanted to be a boy
and she goes why do you want to be a boy
honey and she goes because I want to be
a firefighter and you have to be a boy
to be a firefighter so that just broke
my heart and I said okay this is the
impact that I'm changing with these
dolls yeah absolutely what you just said
is so powerful and such great messaging
for kids that you can be anything girl
or boy um I heard that you're working on
other projects as well though right yeah
so I have three of these dolls okay
that's Molly that you're holding there
and Molly is named after Molly Williams
who is the first known female
firefighter in the United States back in
1815 so I wanted to dedicate this doll
to Molly Williams and her service to the
fire service she was really good
firefighter and I just wanted to
dedicate it to her and the other two
dolls names are ash and Ember and those
are just fire reference names so that
you can you know be a little firefighter
um but these dolls actually promote uh
to help other firefighters in need such
as cancer on the job injuries so I
started a foundation called the trip F
foundation and I myself beat breast
cancer so I wanted to help other
firefighters that might be going through
the same well congratulations one on
beating breast cancer and two thank you
so much for your service and what you do
for us thank you so so much there are no
words really I'm liking your post right
now and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pen of the Kelly Clarkson show love what
you're doing to support female
firefighters so they're going to be
writing triple f a check for $1,000
how's that sound oh my gosh that's
amazing no thank you so much Tina once
again for your service thank you and
thank you to all our guests this hour
Darius Rucker Nikki grer AA lawence and
yall have a great day not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home